she's known for her dramatic screaming
and crying and her seemingly dark power
to predict death the Banshee is seen as
terrifying female spirit and Irish
mythology but is she really all that
terrifying although some of today's pop
culture has weaponized the Banshee
screams
[Music]
and made that an object of fear
the first banshees weren't evil or even
dangerous she not only predicts your
death
but helps you prepare for it this is one
monster you might actually want on your
side
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
going back to at least the 8th century
Irish folk tradition depicts the Banshee
as the spirit or ghost of a once living
woman banshees appear in two different
forms as a withered tiny crone with
white hair or as a tall thin beautiful
woman
the typical band sheet has long flowing
hair and appears dressed in white many
times the woman's spirit becomes a
banshee because of some injustice in her
life because of bad or improper things
she did as a living woman or was a
victim of violence
banshees only appear alone and basically
their sole purpose is to warn the living
when death is coming
they fir warn the living of death by
crying screaming and clapping the old
Irish word Banshee directly translates
to faerie woman the etymologists and
folklores agree that she originally
meant Otherworld so the name actually
means woman of the Otherworld what's
especially unique about the banshee is
that they're only devoted to certain
people
the ancient Gaelic nobility most often
people who have a surname that begins
with O Nick or Mack a different banshee
belonged to each noble family and would
forewarn deaths sometimes appearing to
the family servants she is said to be an
ancestor of the family herself in many
ways the Banshee is a protector of the
family and its noble land even a symbol
of the family if any part of the
ancestral home is still standing even if
it's a ruin she will appear sidenote
although my mom's ancestors came from
the Munster province in Ireland which is
full of Banshee myths her family name is
Welsh so unfortunately no banshees for
me Banshee legends became less common in
the 16th and 17th centuries possibly
because this is when the British
government confiscated Irish land the
English families who moved to Ireland
couldn't have a banshee
since they did not have Irish ancestry
even if they did seize a noble title you
can take my title but you can never take
my Banshee many old bands
stories are even classified by the name
of the family they are loyal to a famous
author Thomas Crofton Crocker includes
the bun worth Banshee and the McCarthy
Banshee and his book of Irish folklore
in both stories the male heirs death is
preceded by the wailing and clapping of
a banshee
so the banshees appearance warns of
impending death but why the screaming
and moaning these expressions of
mourning come from Irish religious and
cultural history women have played a
crucial role in the Irish culture of
death from the very beginning and their
mythology the ancient Celtic Bal goddess
cat abhava is also known as five a
variant of her name just happens to be
the south eastern irish name for banshee
five was said to not only influence
battles but predict the deaths of
notable warriors by a loud wail and cry
she could also shape-shift into a crow
an ability some banshees have as well
another goddess Brigid was said to be
the first in all of Ireland to cry and
lament a death out of her son yet
another connection between women death
and crime or rather keening in the Irish
tradition Keenan is a rhythmic wailing
and mourning performed by women as part
of the death ritual Keeney was seen as
necessary for the dead to pass safely
into the next world keening women were
respected professionals and performers
who guided mourners through grief with
crying and singing they were viewed as
in between worlds the link between the
living world and the other world oh and
did I mention that yet another name for
the banshee is bond Quinta which in
Gaelic literally means keening woman
since their actions were seen as
necessary they were allowed to ignore
social customs while performing keening
women might walk barefoot traveling not
on the roads but through untamed
countries
they would appear disheveled in torn
clothes and unpinned and uncombed hair
they were outsiders and these physical
attributes only serve to emphasize their
otherworldly responsibilities
despite the supernatural air surrounding
keening women they served a very
practical function in times of grief
they acted as a catharsis since they
were paid professionals for a time only
wealthy members of society could afford
one including those old noble families
so makes sense at the banshee who are in
many ways the ghost forum of the keening
woman would only be associated with the
upper-class goddesses keening women and
banshees it's pretty easy to see that
women controlled the voice of death in
Ireland but I also have another theory
one that I think explains the accounts
of banshees shrieking barn owls hear
meow barn owls make a truly terrifying
screaming sound are they are currently
endangered in Ireland they used to be
widely spread across the country barn
owls are nocturnal hunting and
screeching at night and the stories that
I read banshees only appear at night the
Owls horrifying screeching could have
made its way into the Banshee myth
maybe someone heard a barn out his cry
in the darkness the night before a death
in the family and connected it to the
keening banshee that also marks death
the Banshee legend not only links Irish
people to their ancestors but emphasizes
their belief in the supernatural the
Otherworld is important to the creation
of their literary and oral histories
with elements of mythical ancient
goddesses and real-life keening women
she conducts other worlds as well fact
and fiction
PBS Digital Studios wants to hear from
you we plan a survey every year so we
can find out what kind of stuff you're
into you can tell us about your favorite
channels and even get to go on new shows
so click the link take the survey and
don't forget to mention Bob Stroh do you
have a favorite monster a myth you'd
like to see on the show let me know in
the comments and click that little Bell
icon so you can stay updated on the
latest episodes of monstrum
[Music]